let's bring in Kevin Millar he won a
World Series with the Red Sox back in oh
four course one of the star analysts for
the Major League Baseball Network and
co-host have intentionally talked with
Chris Rose on MLB Network at 5:00
Eastern Kevin in the moment what did you
think AJ Hinch should have done when he
went out to talk to Zack Greinke Godley
we're watching the same game right Zack
Greinke is absolutely painting the
baseball nothing was above the knees and
you're thinking man they happen to
follow the infield it felt like and they
really you know until obviously Ren
downs changeup that he hit out that I
mean that kid that boy could hit it just
felt like you need to he need to stay in
the game you know you just you just
watching the contact and once again I
always talk about this game we lose our
eyes because everything's kind of
premeditated it seems like like third
timer on line this guy up it was one of
those things that is an esse couch you
know I'm with you I don't care who you
bring in it other than Gerrit Cole it
seemed like he was up there and it kind
of had that intimidation factor when you
see the big starter out there and Howie
Kendrick's comes up and boom has a nice
piece of hitting and been home without
that foul ball yeah and I want to credit
the Nationals because they did what
great teams do they produce when they
needed to it's just I thought the Astros
were playing I needed them to be more
aggressive here I would have left
Greinke in because I didn't you know he
made a mistake on a changeup but other
than that he was pitching really well
and he to only thrown 80 pitches and if
you're gonna bring it I don't have
Gerrit Cole up unless I'm bringing him
in I'm not wait and you had the lead so
you know and then AJ Hinch saying well I
didn't want to bring him in till we had
the lead okay we see how that worked and
then all I want to bring him in at the
start of an inning a clean inning okay I
just I I don't know I I was really
surprised that if you don't if you're
gonna take out rank e then bring in the
hammer and just send a message over
there to the Nationals like hey you got
Scherzer well we got Cole yeah yeah you
know and you know what Danny it plays
also with the name on that jersey I mean
we remember this Bumgarner seen in 14 it
was like nobody's gonna beat him and you
kind of remembered I mean and he saw the
Cole thing he was that guy
you kind of felt the Scherzer injury he
felt terrible for him when he couldn't
match up with coal in Washington and
then there was something like boom was
he really that hurt I mean he woke up
with the neck and on stuff but was it
that bad because hey if we're going to
lose the coal and Strasburg can get us
to Game six then guess what we have
Scherzer in Game seven it felt like it
kind of worked that way out in the
Nationals like man this worked out great
straws did great in six here we go in
Game seven
this game was you know flown by me both
pitchers were battling obviously great
he looked amazing and Scherzer was doing
what he did he just gets out and grinds
you eat you everything has and then BOOM
how he can drink like a what it was it
felt not tell me if I'm wrong it felt
like like the Houston Astros
you know everybody art is getting their
rings you know sized you know felt like
no one really gave the maps any credit
other than you know we haven't seen a
series in the history of this game that
a home team's number one and then check
out the stat the last couple or the last
I don't name it was last year hockey
basketball and baseball home teams
before last night were three and 16 home
teams look at you sit out of the day
there that was yes they are
mark matching more wonderful research
department I'm like really three and 16
home teams for the games of basketball
yeah yeah just in just in general in
those playoffs okay if if you somebody
didn't see the Nationals how would you
explain how they did this you know
looked at this team Danny they were what
were they 1933 Knights whatever was you
know yeah and then and then you look at
this team the three-headed monster sure
Strasburg Patrick Corbin we never give
him credit he struck out 230 guys this
year they were a monster team Ren don't
urns into who he is he's always been a
very solid player just kind of
underrated because we're in saying you
know then you get a chance to watch him
for seven days and everybody going I
mean Chris Russo is on yes I don't say
baseball baseball that games fixed over
time like baseball he's been do this all
year Rice University who's great he just
he's not a great sound bite but you
to kick play you're like he's a
ballplayer defensively offensively
handles a bat is first at-bat game six
little face it through the right side so
they have a lot of great themes now you
get a chance to watch and you watch for
seven straight days national television
they're pretty damn good ball club
they're scrappy they have that little
that little you know believe in us
behind the scenes no one else going to
give us a chance and they jump on their
bandwagon here they are if they were the
same price Strasburg or Gerrit Cole I
mean we we just now we we've seen the
answer question Gerrit Cole period we've
seen the development of Strasburg
overnight 2012 and it wasn't his fault
you know we got on him when they didn't
let him pitch in the postseason right
what kind of golly we got on the net
it's an organization's you know problem
I think they basically they create these
tampered situations because they're
first-round picks and then oh my god
their investments and all the stuff you
can't see the rains off and you can't
see straws and a nice mental state now
you feel like he's a man now you know
and and I tell you what it was fun to
watch him kind of grow and and you know
you can flip a coin but I take care of
Cole but we're talking to Kevin Millar
from the MLB Network if you're looking
at Gerrit Cole feels like he's gone
Strasburg will opt out to probably
re-sign Rendon can you afford him I mean
look at some of these potential free
agents here because you got a couple of
big ticket items here well put them down
we're gonna wait all offseason because
they're all represented by fours but you
put down Ren don't ever get the Rangers
Cole abused Anaheim Strasburg the
interesting does he resigned back with
the NASA does he opt out try again at
west coast maybe the Padres make it big
move it up but it'll be interesting
because you got an opt-out and there's
no doubt in my mind Strasbourg's gotta
go even though there's 100 million left
on that contract oh yeah yeah he's he'll
opt out but that doesn't mean he's gonna
leave but you think Rendon has gone to
the Rangers and Gerrit Cole to the
Angels you feel that way UCLA boy he's
West Coast home you hit Fritzi ever
chancing afraid she'd go somewhere you
want to go I mean if he looks
comfortable and happy here in Houston
too but I'm sure he's going to
you know you get you get family involved
and wife's and all kinds of stuff so
UCLA fight he ends up on the west side
and I think Rendon ends up your Houston
or I mean now Houston hey how about this
how about this yeah knee
trach area for some young pitching move
Bregman too short
when don't signed by the Houston Astros
how about that November October
thirty-first deal good like it good luck
with that you don't love it mmm to say
that loud before you go home I don't
it's not that I don't like it I just
don't know the likelihood of it like I
like to know the likelihood of something
before I like it great point but I like
to start the stuff Thank You bud we
appreciate your time as always I'm glad
you're back buddy
thank you Kevin that's Kevin Milan for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]